how many people does it take to create a
movement and it's like one one guy can
tell a bunch of people to do something
and then they all start telling people
to do the thing yeah it's like with your
thing with Santa Claus Big Time Santa
Claus by the way to have a conversation
with your
children I'm I'm not going to say it out
loud because there's a lot of people
listening question
everything I walked in and Ian was
Skyping with two kids they were crying
and he was like it's either you know now
or never Dan want Danny wants me to be a
Santa
Claus you get a job with B Santa and
then when the kid sit on your goes what
do you want for Santa he goes I'm not
real yeah the Santa Claus thing freaks
me out it's not that so much about Santa
it's about lying to children come on you
can't no see what happens you guys
YouTube you can't let people tell people
that Santa Claus is real that's
misinformation that isation going to be
a m Santa the kid's going to sit in his
lap and he's and he's gonna go I'm not
really Santa my name's Ian crossin and
then the kid's going to go home and put
up like Ian Crossland pictures and Mom
Santa's real name is Ian's Ian coming
down the chipy